papa
[Musique]
munich ou paris tout simplement munich à
paris et plus précisément au cirque
d'hiver transformé pour un mois en
bourse tube bavaroise à l'occasion de la
fête de la bière
à
ambiance évidemment folklorique avec
leur caisse ludwick maiden ambiance dans
laquelle le parisien se plonge avec
délice le parisien qui n'oublie pas pour
autant de plongées dans son pot degrés
[Musique]
la bière est naturellement la reine de
la fête et ludwig meisel que vous voyez
ici en pleine performance sont rois
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
un roi qui se porte bien
à la fête de la bière on apprend au
moins une chose
la contenance des différents pots le
baron contient elle milite le mas 1
litre le duc de libre le grand duc 3
l'ip et le chevalier s'invite à pau
réservé uniquement aux buveurs sérieux
et maintenant à votre bonne santé et que
la fête continue binationaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh